your boy Joe Biden fell asleep during an
interview it seems I don't think he fell
asleep this is this is what the clip is
this is
and we have time to make that decision
uh Dr Biden is for it
Mr President oh Dr Biden thinks that uh
my wife thinks that uh
that I
that that were that were doing something
very important
I mean it's not great it doesn't fall
asleep he ain't fall asleep but which is
worse I'd rather than fall asleep than
answer like that awake but that's a
little rough nah why do you think the
interview stay awake why do you think
the interviewer was like hello right he
gotta die soon yeah but that I mean he
falls asleep mid interview yeah I mean
yeah he gonna die soon bro is that news
to everybody he's gonna die why was the
interviewer like oh are you Mr President
hello
I'm not because he's worried he's dying
on camera you don't wanna be the
interview to kill Joe Biden I mean he
probably does bro like that he's not
actually going gum virus yeah yeah no
that's true that'd be good for your
career in a weird way but you don't
think this is this is a sign of mental
decline yeah I think his yeah we all
know yeah I thought that was from House
of dragon that was viserys right yeah no
this air is way more eloquent so Sarah
was missing half of his body but like
this is just a bad look for America like
don't don't let him or deep fake it
that's why I don't believe the Deep fake
[ __ ] because I'm like if deep fake one
was real we would be deep thinking yeah
I mean it's embarrassing it's it is
absolutely embarrassing it is it is a
complete disrespect of the seat of
office like how are we supposed to
believe that that's the most powerful
man in the world like to me it exposes
whatever the conspiracies are the Deep
State or the real people in power or
whatever because if he's supposed to be
the real person in power if that's what
330 million Americans are supposed to
think there's no way we're letting him
make all the decisions in his current
state right yeah so when we all look at
this and we go oh he's not really
pulling the strings pulling the strings
then we have to go who is now we're
looking at all these other people it's
like you're exposing Yourself by being
in this situation and the fact that they
haven't put a single person else up like
is there another Democrat you can think
that's crazy it's not that's crazy I
don't even understand what's happening
like Kamala they hate and I get they do
that by purpose they're like they're due
on purpose like to ensure the the the
the the protection of the president you
get an absolutely idiotic running mate
right like that's you know what I mean
like that's what Trump did with Pence
everybody looked at Pence we're like we
can't have this [ __ ] weird over doing
running the goddamn country right and
that's what Biden does with Kamala and
that's what Obama did with Biden they
didn't think that might actually be
[ __ ] president yeah yeah I mean it's
unbelievable it's kind of wild then do
you see this other one of him it can't
wait no I mean like he has to say that
hey I'm not running he's not one no he
doesn't want to give it up yeah but out
of respect nobody's gonna step up and be
like yeah cause yeah they got uh Buddha
judge
like they they got people that they can
throw up there who why is he saying that
he's running again that's what I'm
getting yeah
president you want to give it up who's
the Democrats DeSantis sorry to cut you
but like who is the Democrats DeSantis
who's the Democrat they have the [ __ ]
Gavin uh Newsome I know that we we're
shaking her ahead at that because the
guy seems like like such an absolute
[ __ ] phony fraud yeah but I really
don't like the guy but he is the only
one sorry it's he's gonna defend look
what I did for California California is
a [ __ ] disaster he'll literally
defend like that
people be forgetting about [ __ ] I'm
telling you have to understand it San
Francisco and L.A they don't they're
tough I understand how you feel
personally most people do not live in
California exactly one two they're not
voting for him they're voting for not
the other person yes so all they have to
do is vilify the other person enough
where you go well I can't support that
I'll go with this guy who I don't think
is that good I mean what happened this
last election right I understand I don't
think anybody looking by and they're
like he's the [ __ ] truth I understand
that but I'm saying you put DeSantis and
you put Gavin side by side you say
they're our only argument look what I
did for Florida look what I did for
California people don't know from
California I'm gonna go digging on
DeSantis and they're gonna make him look
like every horrible thing that if you
were liberal you would absolutely be
terrified by and then
you know that's the nuisance a bit more
charismatic in my opinion you know what
though and you've said this before I
think America's gonna vote on safety and
you're going to feel safer they're just
gonna destroy look at La is it's a war
zone and then if you're worried about
safety which most people are at the end
of the day you're just worried about
safety
you're gonna go with the Republican guy
over the guy are you gonna go with the
guy who is the uh governor of
arguably the most dangerous state in the
[ __ ] Union yeah which is Florida oh
really I mean the way that the world
perceives Florida Florida man does
method and shoots blah blah shots in
Florida so what they'll do is they'll go
oh you can't say my State's more
dangerous look at the murder rate your
state look at all these people that get
shot in your state look at the drug
problems in your state look at the
illegal trafficking in your state right
like the idea of Florida is not
necessarily a safe place what it was is
a place free of the coveted restrictions
which we all loved so I I don't even
think that DeSantis can go at California
for being that dangerous when you
compare it to fly I don't think you
can't compare Florida doesn't have that
stink perception wise definitely he
could they could label them they can
label them
I mean I know how passionate you are
about this
the entire country like look what
Charlemagne says he goes the the
craziest people on the planet are from
the Bronx in Florida yes it is like fact
you may be because you're West Coast but
at least on the East Coast okay
we don't have that perception there's
Florida man methy perception that's very
Niche you're talking about one state the
most the most populated state in the
country I don't think Trump's running
man you heard what he said at that rally
he's like I probably gotta run and
people went crazy I think that he likes
the political influence he has now now
from saying that he's gonna run because
he controls a part of the base so as
long as he's like honor with with the
I'm gonna fight again like it allows you
to have influence within the sport and
allows you to use that influence for
your other business Endeavors so if
everybody got to be nice to Trump
because they want him to support them he
can use that for influence not only in
business but maybe in not getting hemmed
up in this [ __ ] courtship he's still
got open cases he he might have a
conversation with DeSantis and say if
you win I need you to make sure I don't
go to jail and I'm going to throw all my
support behind you or he has a
conversation with the Dem and says hey
I'm not going to trash you I just need
you to make sure that I'm good once you
win but I mean he could do that for
himself no there's no upside for him to
say he's not running a win I don't think
he's I don't think he thinks he can win
genuinely I think if Biden runs maybe
just because I don't know if anybody in
their right mind could vote for about it
but that's something that's what it
looks like I don't know if he believes
in his heart that he can beat DeSantis
and I think that he's been incredibly
he's made be made incredibly radioactive
and he's played a part of that and I
think he's lost some of his bass but he
doesn't want to relinquish that
political control right now couldn't he
run independently yeah yeah but yeah but
he would just split the Republicans
he wants to take the party if they don't
give him the nomination he's just like
[ __ ] well I think he says he does that
if they don't provide some uh assurance
that they won't put him in prison that's
a point he's got a lot of chips yeah and
I think he's if he says I'm not going to
run then he loses the chips and all
these people they go search for somebody
else but these like hard-line trumpers
they're basically please Daddy Run
please Daddy run and
he has to hold them until the official
announcement is like Game of Thrones yo
it is so interesting like 100 and I I
wonder if like I wish they had dragons
yeah right yeah I wonder if like big
money corporations and businesses are
it's always like that like just think
about it like
the Elon Musk has to get a certain
amount of nickel out of
the Democratic Republic of the Congo in
order to make the batteries for his cars
if you don't think that he's lobbying
certain countries
politicians
uh CIA whatever other kind whatever the
other version of the CIA is for these
other countries you don't think that
he's lobbying to make sure that those
mines are kept open and free to run and
unaffected by terrorism and unaffected
by War like you're talking about like a
very tumultuous part of the world right
the Congo right and these mines work all
the time
and nobody's [ __ ] with the mind yeah
you think that's a coincidence no you're
playing [ __ ] chess all right you are
playing [ __ ] chess to make sure that
everybody get their batteries you think
he shows his feet say again you think he
shows his feet off to some guy I think
he got he got a lot of he got a lot of
good will when he showed off that body
that's true he's on that boat but yeah I
think all these guys you want to expand
you want like global
those are the conversations I just like
to hear hey we need to get this amount
of nickel out of there there's one place
to get it on the planet Democratic
Republic of Congo
in complete disarray
who do we got to promise it to um
you know what I did yeah like I don't
doubt it rich people are doing smart
[ __ ] to stay rich
you don't get rich by playing by the
rules yeah and I'm not I'm not I'm not
necessarily even criticizing I'm just
like Curious like who do you have to
like you got to go to the warlord that
you know is like making kids [ __ ]
become soldiers like chopping off their
feet and [ __ ] and you got to go hey
here's this much money so we can keep
doing that yeah
don't you on some level yeah I guess you
probably have to and that is the world
like we all wear the sneakers that are
made by the kids like we're not he's no
worse than us I guess
there's levels but I just want to know
what that conversation I want to know
the [ __ ] Bezos conversation yeah I
just want to know what these are like
and like maybe they feel guilt about it
maybe it's a tax combo like even
internally like with like the politician
that you put in power be like hey like
yeah don't rule over the tax [ __ ] or
like don't push the tax thing in my
direction keep it over here yeah make
these loopholes keep them open yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm so curious if it's if
it's Direct
hey we're having these conversations
like up front or if it's like implied
like yeah help me out I had a
little I don't wanna but there was a
thing that happened and uh that was
gonna affect real estate prices in like
a big way
and immediately when this new politician
entered the office he
stopped it and he stopped it because of
one phone call crazy wow I wonder how
many one phone calls happen every day
and how many people in power and like
low-key like
that being in that position and having
that power
it's just like I don't want to compare
it to [ __ ] like Game of Thrones or
like any of these things but it's like
yeah that's the exhaustion it's not
walking around and giving speeches all
day and like inspiring people it's like
I'm gonna get a call today and I'm gonna
have to piss off 50 of the people that
live in this place yeah or I'm gonna get
a call from two people that are asking
different things and I gotta figure out
who I would want to [ __ ] over yeah it's
crazy and I think that's why
you you look at like a a guy like Obama
where a lot of people are like oh he's
you know myself included but when he
initially said he was going to run for
government or one for run for president
I was like ah so early wave a little bit
you don't wait yeah because the longer
you wait the more times you've [ __ ]
over ah yeah like Nancy Pelosi can never
run for president because she's done so
many horrible things yeah they'll just
look at the record like what'd they do
with Biden Biden's been in government so
long he said the n-word in front of
people record it right now within the
context of a sentence he's quoting
people but still like that is like yeah
yeah so it's almost you want people to
be out of it because the longer you're
in it you're gonna do something [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna have dirt you're gonna
have dirt
I don't to me like how do we have a
dinner and learn about that that's what
I think the Illuminati is it's not like
an organized like controlled thing it's
just all the cute like the cumulative
interpersonal relationships amongst like
marketing or like uh media Executives
corporate Executives and politicians
yeah and they all kind of know each
other and they all know who the players
are and who's pulling the levers yeah
and then it's like happening at like one
dinner party and then another dinner
party and then a weekend getaway and
then an aspen yeah it's all happening
yeah it's like that interpersonal
relationship I don't think it's
centralized it's not organized there's
not like one person on top that that's
what you're saying yeah exactly yeah
like they don't have meetings yeah they
also use the term they yeah it's just
other days yeah yeah yeah you just reach
the top I guess of it's not only
government but it's government and
Industry and those things intermingle
it's not a Jewish cabal
that's what we're getting to yeah
exactly yeah it would be so much easier
if it was and I think that's probably
why people simplify it right they go oh
it's just these people they're doing it
because it's harder to accept what you
you said which is really the reality
yeah like they are the Illuminati
doesn't know they're the Illuminati uh
exclusively yeah they're also frustrated
by other vase making decisions but it is
a thing though there are powerful people
that are pulling strings but it's not
organized 100 this is the group and
we're all a part of this group but yeah
Thursday at three yeah that's the whole
thing they are they're upset with each
other yeah yeah they're like oh wait why
the [ __ ] did Raytheon get this [ __ ] yeah
we're Lockheed Mark yeah like they're
not the same base yeah yeah and there's
energy they gave it to Raytheon